so in this class this semester I'm
making three big predictions right first
is that Trump will
win uh in November second is that um
United States will go to war against
Iran and the third big big prediction is
that the United States will lose this
war which will forever change the global
order um the
past uh so last class we looked at one
reason why the United States would
invade Iran uh which is the Israel Lobby
and in today's class we'll look at
another reason which is the defense of
Empire America is an Empire and it must
defend its Imperial
status
so let's
examine what an Empire means for America
so from 1950
to
1980 America's economy was mainly
focused on manufacturing factories okay
so um manufacturing as a share of GDP
was
40% it made 40% of
profits okay and and employed 30% of the
workforce so during World War II uh
America had a lot of factories produce
weapons and after World War III these
factories produce consumer goods cars
electronics to sell to the world and
this
made um the American
workers the wealthiest and most well
educated middle class ever in human
history if you were a factory worker
from 1950 to
1980 you had a really good life um you
worked 40 hours
a week you had health insurance you
could buy your own
house your wife didn't have to work you
could have three to four kids you could
have two cars every year you could go on
vacation to some to some place nice you
could eat out once a week and then you
retired and had a very good pension so
it was really the best
life um and so
workers from 1950 1980 in America were
really the luckiest people on the planet
you were better off actually being born
into the middle class in America then
you were being born rich in Africa or
Asia or South America
okay but then after 1980 was something
called the Reagan
Revolution and the introduction of what
we call
neoliberalism and remember that we
studied neoliberalism before NE
neoliberalism is a economic philosophy
that believes in the Primacy of free
markets and
deregulation um so after that we now
live in today what we call a financial
economy okay the economy has been
financialized and so what does that mean
it means that right now Financial
Services okay account for
22% of all GDP in America manufacturing
has gone down to 10% so went down from a
high of 40% to now a low of 10%
Financial Services is now
twice as much as
manufacturing Financial Services
bringing
40% of all
profits and financial services employs
5%
of the total American
Workforce okay now let me explain what
these numbers mean what you're seeing
behind these numbers is a
radical shift overhaul transition in
American society okay let let's just
look at politics politics
governance from this period 195 19
1980 um American workers had a lot of
political power right because they were
middle class they were confident they
participated in politics for unions okay
today most of this power has shifted to
the financial services which basically
means Wall
Street and working for Wall Street are
what we called um the
professional manager
Elite okay so these are people who live
on the coast San Francisco New York
Washington DC Boston they went to Elite
schools okay the ivy
league um and they're
Multicultural and right now they're the
most powerful political group in America
and this has led to massive political
divisions within the country okay so
it's the first major consequence
before it was workers who had uh a large
say over American politics and now it is
Wall Street the financial sector and the
coastal Professional Management uh Elite
and so government chapes policies that
favors this Multicultural Elite
Financial Elite over at the expense of
workers okay so that's the first major
shared but then you look
at um
education and so what I mean by that is
that you know if you went to a good
school a good University in 1950s and
1960s your ambition was to become a
professor right or maybe a scientist or
maybe an
entrepreneur uh or a corporate executive
okay
nowadays most people who graduate from
these top
schools all want to go
where Wall Street and that's it okay why
because you make more money on Wall
Street than anywhere else okay so you're
talking about these phds in statistics
and artificial intelligence who should
be working for
IBM um developing the latest technology
right instead they're on Wall Street
working for a hedge fund get gambling
with other people's
money okay so basically the economy has
gone has gone from one that is um
productive or
creative to one that is entirely
speculative okay so remember that finan
the financial services all it does is
take people's money and gamble with it
or invest in it to make more money okay
it's not actually productive it's all it
is is speculative
okay and the smartest people in America
the most well educated are all
focused on this
sector okay and then you look
at um the
economy and what has clearly changed is
that the economy in America has become
much more
unstable so in 2001 there was the
internet crash right the do crash in
2008 there was the financial crisis
right the sub crime uh crash and then
after that you have all the um you have
these Banks going bankrupt okay I think
like this past week three Banks went
bankrupt in
America this should not be happening and
the reason why this is happening are all
these um bubbles okay so in other words
all assets right now in America over
pric okay housing stock
market um and people are
gambling that these asset prices will
only go higher which creates Bubbles and
when these bubbles burst you have
volatility and instability and
uncertainty okay so this is bad for the
uh
economy and then you you have things
like
inequality
right so um if you look at profits if
you look at wealth generation the top 1%
make much more money than everyone else
and this inequality is only
increasing okay so in other words the
financialization of the econ of the
American economy has been really bad for
America and you can make the argument
that it's actually
destroying the fabric of American
society okay it's making politics much
more divisive it's making the economy
much more volatile the smartest people
are engaged in speculative
activities young people don't want to
work they just want to buy
Bitcoin um and you can also make the
argument that you're creating a
rentier economy okay and a rentier
economy just means that if you are young
you can never afford to buy a house you
can only rent which means that you
yourself can never go from you you have
no more social Mobility okay so this
overall is really bad for America now
the question then is how did America get
to this point how how did it how did it
transition from a manufacturing economy
to a financial
economy and there are different theories
out there okay there are some economists
who say that this is just late stage
capitalism okay this is the Natural
Evolution of capitalism there are some
who argue that it is the neoliberalism
or the regular Revolution that CED this
okay when you take when you cut back the
role of government when you emphasize
free
markets um
then you have this situation the over
financialization of the economy okay
what I want to show you today is that
the real reason is the transition to
Empire okay there's a really simple
explanation for why this is happening
and the reason is that after the end of
the Cold War
1991 America became a global Empire it
could Now set the rules of the game and
it set the rules of the game so that it
would always win
and then all money flow to America which
created um all these asset
bubbles okay so uh that's the argument
um I'm making to you today okay
so um are we clear about what's
happening any questions so
far okay now I want to explain to you
how America became an empire in fact the
most powerful Empire in human history
because even though Rome was powerful it
didn't really control the world whereas
America the American Empire Today
controls the entire world okay and so to
understand how America became an Empire
you have to go back to the founding of
America okay so in
1776 America declared independence from
Britain and at that time they had
something called the Declaration
of
Independence and the Declaration of
Independence if you read the document
it's very clear it's what the founding
fathers of America said is that we are
founding a new
Society in America based on God okay now
the founding fathers were Christians but
they were a special type of Christians
who believe in the idea of
theism and theism is the idea that
yes there is a
God um and the go and God they create
everything but God is not interested in
managing human Affairs God leaves us
alone which means that we as humans are
empowered to create the world we want to
create okay and the founding fathers
want to to create a new Society based
on um the idea of God okay and what they
believed is that God gave human beings
three
fundamental rights that all governments
must respect okay and so the famous
phrase is do you guys know the famous
phrase
life
liberty and the
pursuit of
happiness okay that is the mission the
purpose
of America to ensure that every
American would have life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and that's really
the goal the role of government life to
to to make you safe okay Pro to provide
security against enemies
Liberty the right to say whatever you
believe the right to believe whatever
you believe okay so the tolerance of all
Creeds religions the last is the pursuit
of happiness what does Pursuit of
Happiness mean you guys know so Thomas
Jefferson wrote the Declaration of
Independence and when he wrote The
Pursuit of
Happiness he had a very specific idea in
mind what what does the pursuit of
happiness
mean uh which is
what okay so wellth
okay so in America your fundamental
right the fundamental purpose of your
life is to make as much money as you can
to amass as much wealth as you can okay
and the idea here is
that in this Society in this new Society
this new experiment called America if we
allow everyone to
pursue uh the creation of wealth then
America will become powerful okay that's
the idea and it turned out that this
idea
was absolutely correct okay in a very
short amount of time
America industrialized very
rapidly and at the end of World War II
America became the most powerful country
in the
world okay after World War
II it decided that um it can now export
its philosophy to the rest of the world
so in
1944 there's something called the Breton
Woods
conference okay and so in 1944 everyone
knew that Nazi Germany would be defeated
okay and Japan would be defeated which
would make America the most powerful the
richest
nation um on the planet okay now the
Soviet Union was a
competitor but they didn't really matter
okay they had their own sphere of
influence so America got got together
with its allies in Europe and they
decided what the new Global Financial
system would look like and the idea was
that with Brendon woods they decided
that the US
dollar would become the global Reserve
currency which basically meant that you
could buy anything with the US
dollar now there are some people at um
Bron Woods um some economists who were
afraid that this would cause problems
right if you have a government which was
in control of the global Reserve
currency that would basically make the
government God right if they could just
print as much money as they wanted they
could become like Midas if they touch
something it it would become gold okay
so some people thought it was dangerous
and so the compromise is that the US
dollar had to be backed by gold okay the
gold
standard in other words the US dollar
was basically like a receipt for gold if
you had a million dollars okay you could
go to any American bank and get a
million dollars worth of gold for it
okay does that make sense so that's what
we call the gold standard and for the
longest and so that lad this this bread
and WT system led to tremendous
prosperity in America and in Europe
Europe and Japan okay then in
1971 Richard Nixon did something really
radical he basically
said we America we're going to get we're
going to go off the gold standard okay
uh remember that America had spent too
much money on the space rise on Vietnam
on domestic expenses okay so they needed
to transition out of the gold
standard but if you trans transition out
of the gold
standard then how do
you um ensure the US dollar is worth
something how do you ensure the
intricate worth of the US dollar so they
transition from the gold Center to what
do you guys
know oil okay do you understand this
what we call the Petro
dollar and the idea here is that look
every economy needs oil to to um run
right you need oil as the basis of your
economy and so after America went off
the gold standard these countries in the
Middle East meaning Saudi Arabia but
other countries as well agreed that you
could buy oil using US
dollars so um the idea is okay before if
you had a million dollars a million US
Dollars you could change convert that to
Gold okay and now you can convert it to
oil and this what we call the Petr
dollar and this is really the basic
is uh for the value of the US dollar
today
okay so then what happened is that in
1991 the um Soviet Union fell and now
America was in charge of the
entire uh global economy basically okay
and so America at that time said to
everyone listen let's focus on trade
because trade trade will make everyone
Rich okay so let me explain the theory
of this okay so America basically wanted
um everyone to
trade and the idea of trade okay this is
like uh Russia China okay South America
the idea of trade is that each country
would focus on its competitive Advantage
what are you good at and then you would
sell this competitive advantage to other
countries for what they're good at okay
and the theory here is that if you do it
this way then all countries will become
rich okay so let me explain why all
right so let's look at uh us and China
okay so what China's really good at is
cheap
labor United States what what United
States is really good at is TE
technology
right okay
so the idea is that United States and
trying to trade
right um so China makes all these cheap
goods for American
consumers but unfortunately Chinese
consumers don't have enough purchasing
power to buy American Technology right
okay so what happens is that
America gives China US Dollars instead
okay trillions and trillions of US
Dollars now in theory what's supposed to
happen is this money trickles
down to the average Chinese so
that the average Chinese worker his
wages go up right and when his wages go
up what he can do now is buy us products
like
iPhones and so over time trade evens out
okay does that make sense that's a
theory okay that that's that's first
Theory the second theory is is how
Capital moves okay and the idea here is
that capital is going to go to
places which allows it to grow the most
okay and so the idea is that when you
have a globalized world then what
happens is capital from the United
States moves to
China right because if you invest in
China your Capital grows the most you
you can buy a million dollar house in
United States
or you can buy 10 houses for the same
money in China so you're better off
buying houses in China right okay so
these these are the two theories one is
that trade will make everyone rich and
second is that Capital will move from
rich countries to poor countries okay
and when you actually go to university
and you study
economics like like jackwell then you
actually have to learn these
theories um but in reality
these two theories aren't true
okay why
not why aren these two theories
true so the first theory is that if you
two countries trade over time
wealth um trickles down to everyone in
that country which makes everyone
richer okay is that true for
China no it's not okay workers wages
have not gone up for the past 30 40
years why because of the idea of elite
capture Elite capture so all the money
is
captured by an elite group of people
when that
happens okay they can't spend it they
can't buy us Goods right so only thing
they can do is invest
it right now according to this Theory
they should invest it back in China
because if you investment in China
should allow for more growth than in
than investment anywhere else okay but
but in reality where where do they put
their
money in the United States and why would
they do
that
why exactly okay you don't put your
money where you make the most money you
put your money where it's the most safe
okay that's why we have Banks
so because the United States controls
the US dollar and because people's
wealth uh is expressing US Dollars it
makes the most sense to put your money
in United States okay and this is not
just just true for China it's true for
most countries in the world and that's
why um starting in the 90s you have all
this wealth amassing in the United
States okay does that make sense so
everything in United States became
overpriced everything became a
speculative bubble okay so let me give
give an example let's let's look at
equities okay stock
market stocks in the year 1900 okay in
the year 1900 if you look at all the
world stock markets the largest was the
UK okay because obviously the UK is the
most powerful country in the world was
the most powerful country at that at
that time what sorry at that time the UK
was the most powerful country
okay so in a stock market as a as a
percentage of the entire Global stock
market was about 25% okay 24 to
25% the United States was second at
14.5% then you had Germany about um 133%
France at 11% okay so that was the
situation of wealth in the year 1900 and
this makes sense right these four
countries are
industrially um extremely
powerful today okay today the year
2024 the United States has
60% of all the world's stock
wealth okay who second can you guys
guess who would be
second Japan okay and what is the
percentage of global stock wealth can
you guys guess a
number United States has 66% 60% how
much does Japan have can you guess a
number 10% is a good guess right it's
actually
6% okay do you see the disparity number
one is 60% Japan number two is
6% it's huge disparity how much is China
the world's second largest economy
3%
okay you
understand right so all this wealth
that's being generated around the world
it can only end up one
place okay the United
States all right
so you have and that's what's that's
what's pushed the
financialization of the US economy okay
because this wealth goes to United
States and someone has to manage this
wealth and that this is the financial
services sector okay so people on Wall
Street and this is very important people
on Wall
Street they make their
money based on how they manage this
wealth not on whether or not they make
money out of this money you
understand they charge a management fee
okay so in other words they're not
actually
incentivized to be conservative and make
sure that this money grows what they're
incentivized to do is design riskier and
riskier um
assets and investment opportunities to
attract more investment and because then
they can take a management fee a cut
okay does that make sense and that's
what's led to so much Financial over
speculation
over the past 20 years in uh
America and one of America's biggest
problems is the growing national debt
okay so the government is paying for a
lot of government services just by
putting money okay so right now the US
national debt is about 34
trillion okay and this $34 trillion debt
half of it is owned by foreigners okay
so Japan has about a trillion uh China
has about 800 billion so they buy us
treasuries okay so America owes Japan a
trillion dollars America owes China $800
billion and then half of it um the
government owes to its people so the two
largest expenses are the military and
the pension system
okay um so $34 trillion is a lot of
money because the US GDP p is about
hundred trillion dollar so the total
debt is about a third of uh America GDP
and this debt has interest right so this
debt is going about one to two one to
two trillion every two to three months
okay and all all this is saying okay
these numbers all they're telling us is
there's ABS no way that America can pay
all this
debt okay
so then the question then is if you're
China and you're J your Japan why do you
have all this debt knowing that America
can never pay you back or uh America
will at some point default on this debt
why why does America why does Japan and
China and other countries have all this
debt your treasuries knowing fully
knowing knowing that America can never
pay back all this debt
why okay so there are many reasons okay
the first reason is that in theory uh
Japan and China can always take this
debt and buy oil with it okay so this
this is again the Petro
dollar second reason is that um even
though America's in debt it's still an
Empire it's still the greatest military
power in the world so at some point you
so so you feel that the money is safe
there okay does that make sense because
no one can actually challenge America
militarily and the third reason and this
is the most important reason
is there's no place for you to go you
understand what do you what what else
where else can you put your money
nowhere okay so that's the issue right
now
and so in
theory
because um China and Japan can buy oil
with it um and
because there's really no place for
China and Japan to put this money in
theory the system can go on forever okay
so it's possible that maybe in um 10
years time the debt will be 340 trli
okay who knows okay so in theory this
could go on forever right because
America's an
Empire but then what happened uh two
three years ago is Russia invaded
Ukraine okay Russia invaded
Ukraine and why this is
important is
that this is basically Russia
challenging the dominance of the
American
Empire okay what put is really saying to
United States is I think your Empire is
full of lies your Empire is based on
nothing your Empire is based on the
perception that you are invincible in
war well I'm going to invade Ukraine and
prove everyone war and prove everyone
wrong okay I'm going to show that you
America are in fact a paper
tiger okay and so if Putin succeeds in
his war in
Ukraine then the fun fundamental
understanding of how the world works
that America is an Empire that America
is Invincible that the US dollar is safe
will radically change okay it will be
destroyed it'll be undermined it'll be
subverted okay does that make sense so
that's why America needs to um stop
Russia um in Ukraine
okay can it stop Russia can it stop can
it stop Russia and
Ukraine how's the war going for America
America and
Ukraine pretty badly okay I mean the war
is almost
over okay so um if so but what America
can
do okay which will which will solve all
these problems is for America to
transition from a financial economy back
to a manufacturing economy okay if
America can if America just does this
America has nothing to worry about it
doesn't have to worry about the debt it
doesn't have to worry about Russia it
doesn't really have to worry about the
world okay because America is a
self-sufficient economy meaning that it
has the resources to sustain itself it
doesn't really need to trade with the
rest of the world okay if America can
return to being a
manufacturing um
economy then it would be
Invincible okay now the question then is
Can America reindustrialize
yes or
no why not
Jack because the politics doesn't allow
them to exactly but can you explain
that
yeah that's exactly right jack okay so
yes the problem right now is the very
structure of American society and
politics and the economy right now the
financial sector has all the power and
they don't want to go back to the time
when manufacturing had all the power
right so that's a first
problem but let's just say for the sake
of argument that they agree to this okay
what's your other
problem if you want to re
reindustrialize
excuse
me um okay but all the foreign
investment can just go into factories
right but there's actually a really big
problem with reindustrialization okay so
as Jack says there will be political
resistance to this okay but then you
have a bigger problem than this which is
what
okay
guys the problem with this economy is it
creates a speculative mindset okay so
therefore no one wants to work hard no
one wants to go want no one wants to go
to work work in factories anymore do you
understand if you're a young person you
would much rather spend your time
investing in Bitcoin than working in a
factory do you understand because
investing in Bitcoin gives you the
opportunity to become rich but if you
work in a factory you have to work hard
for 40 years just to buy a house does
that make sense so you're not going to
find people to work these
factories that's a bigger problem okay
and the third problem of course is just
investment how how do you build these
factories you not only have to build
these factories but you also have to
build Logistics networks to move move
goods from one place to the next okay
okay so
in other words America could
reindustrialize but it's a pain in the
ass right you're you're going to face a
lot of political opposition especially
from the financial sector it's very hard
for you to to to get people to work in
factories and plus where's all this
money going to come from
okay
so if you can't beat Russia in Ukraine
and if you can't
reindustrialize then what can you do to
protect the petrol dollar
and your financial
system well I have an idea
okay invade Iran okay invade
Iran now why would you do that and the
answer is that
unfortunately of all the options out
there okay because America can't just
sit back and let its empire collapse
right of all the options out there
invading Iran happens to be politically
the easiest to
do okay you're not you can't go fight a
war against Russia because Russia has
nuclear weapons you cannot
reindustrialize because there there be
too much political opposition towards
that plus it'll take you about 50 years
to reindustrialize but if you invade
Iran well you accomplish three things
okay the first thing
is you show the world that you're still
the top dog your milary is still
Invincible okay so if you're a foreign
investor in America you you have a
trilon US Dollars you feel safe okay you
don't you don't think the US dollar will
collapse okay that's the first thing to
show the world that America is still the
world's foremost military power
therefore the US dollar is safe okay
second
is um oil right what is the
usar based on oil right well if you
control oil then you don't have to worry
about people abandoning the US dollar
okay does that make sense okay and it
happens that the Middle East uh
produces uh 40% of the world's
oil and Iran is the world's fourth
largest oil exporter but but when you
take over Iran you also control Iraq as
well you control that entire area okay
and the third thing about invading Iran
is trade okay so
um that area most of the World's Trade
has to pass through that area right so
invading Iran would allow you to control
the world's shipping
lanes
okay
so that would be the theory behind
evading Iran okay but the
motivation would be to save the American
Empire because if Putin wins in Ukraine
then America is going to look weak it's
going to look like a paper tiger okay
and in this in this situation as the
Empire you have to
act
today um you have a lot of countries in
Africa who are Reb rebelling against the
Western Powers France basically and and
America why because they think that
Putin is now in charge okay why did
October 7th why did
Hamas uh attack Israel I guarantee you
that if we were not for the war in
Ukraine Hamas would not have done such a
thing
okay for the longest time before the war
in
Ukraine um there was a perception in the
world that America was militarily
invincible
no power no country could ever DARE
stand up against uh the United States
and by invading Ukraine Putin has proved
everyone wrong okay that the United
States can be defeated and so what the
United States must do now is prove to
the world nope we're still militarily
the greatest power in the world okay
does that make
sense okay and
again uh it must do so to prevent to to
protect its Financial economy
otherwise uh there's a very good chance
that this financial Eon economy will
implode onto itself okay if uh China
Japan other countries pull out of the US
financial sector okay if they sell their
us treasuries not only
will um America face a sovereign debt
crisis but it will lose access to Easy
Money okay easy money and the problem in
America today is that America is an
Empire addicted to Easy Money okay
people are so used to just around and
makeing millions of dollars that they
cannot imagine or tolerate a day when
they would have have to go back to
working hard okay so it's this addiction
to easy money which will drive
American um which will drive America to
invade Iran okay does that make sense
okay any
questions okay so um all this money
coming to America how is it managed okay
so this is actually very complicated
okay because again the financial sector
is very large but if you have US Dollars
then your options are you can invest in
the stock market you can invest in um H
houses okay the problem today is because
there are too many rich people in the
world and all this money is going to
America all assets are bubbles now okay
so the irony of all this is
that you feel that your only option is
to invest in America but but when you do
this you're actually losing
value okay and that's why the system is
not really sustainable everyone in
America and that's driving up all these
asset prices but in the long term that
will destroy the American economy and in
the long term uh it it'll create all
these bubbles that will destroy that
will also destroy individual wealth okay
does that make sense any more questions
okay so so so so Jack asks a great
question which is like listen if going
to if going to e to Iran is all about
restoring confidence in United States
well if America loses the war then that
would destroy even more confidence okay
and so this is this is the problem of
Empires empir have something called huis
right Imperial
huis which means that they cannot
imagine the possibility of losing a war
okay so why is that okay there are two
reasons okay there are two reasons the
first reason is that an
Empire what an Empire is it it's it's a
force that imposes reality onto others
okay an Empire makes you see the world
the way the Empire wants you to see the
world okay does that make sense which
means there's no feedback loop which
means that you cannot actually tell the
Empire what you think it doesn't your
voice doesn't matter which means that an
Empire it's not possible for an Empire
to imagine the possibility of it ever
collapsing you understand if it could it
would never
collapse okay that's the first problem
second problem is that okay let's do a
thought experiment if you had a choice
if you had a choice would you rather be
smart and
strategic or stupid and
arrogant if you had a choice in in an
ideal world would you would you rather
be smart and strategic or stupid and
arrogant okay the answer is stupid and
arrogant because it makes you feel good
okay stupid people feel good about
themselves right smart people get
depressed they doubt themselves they
question themselves and that makes you
feel bad most people in an ideal world
would want to feel good themselves
always okay so it so when you are an
Empire you want to be stupid and
arrogant because it makes you feel good
does that make
sense okay but that's why Empires
collapse because once they have too much
power they become stupid and arrogant
and they refuse to consider the
possibility that they could be wrong
okay does that make sense
Jack
okay any more questions
okay uh the American Empire has been
building for a long time okay so you can
make the argument that the Empire really
started after World War to because now
America controlled half the world and
then it became dominant after the after
the end of the Cold War when the Soviet
Union collapsed and at that time okay
before the collapse of the Cold
War Amer had to behave itself and the
reason it had to behave itself was it
wasn't afraid of the Soviet Union it was
afraid of Communism right that's why
from 1950 to 1980 they treat their
workers so well because they were afraid
of a worker Revolt right so the real
threat was not the Soviet Union the real
threat was communism as an opposing
ideology to capitalism Unfortunately
today there's no opposing ideology
towards capitalism okay and that's why
America uh can do what what what it
wants it doesn't it it it does not fear
any enemies it does not fear internal
Revolt okay does that make sense okay
all right so I'll see you guys next week